Now that we talked about the detail of optimization problems
versus decision problems, we are ready to dive in.
So how can we show that a problem is intractable?
We already know how to show that a problem is tractable.
We just have to find a polynomial time algorithm for it.
But how do we find out if the problem is intractable?
And there's actually two different ways we could go about this.
The first way we could try to show intractability is by gathering evidence.
What I mean by gathering evidence is this, we've already found out that Alice, Bob, and Carol
were working on problems for which they weren't able to find a polynomial time algorithm,
but all of their problems were connected, so if one of them managed to find a solution
then all of their problems will be tractable, so one way we could be gathering evidence is
if we just find more people working on more hard problems,
and of course all of them are very smart people.
If we could find more and more people who are also very smart working on very tough problems,
but also no one of them finds a polynomial time algorithm.
We could basically be saying, look, there are so many people who have looked at this problem,
none of them has found out that the problem is tractable, so we think it must be intractable.
Another way to go about this would be a mathematical proof.
And what a mathematical proof would have to show is that no matter what kind of intricate,
ingenious, sophisticated, complex algorithm we use for a problem,
that algorithm will still need exponential time to solve the problem.
So, what I would like you to think about for our next quiz is
the advantages and disadvantages of each of these approaches here.
And I would like you to think about two things.
First of all, which of these approaches is probably easier to accomplish?
And secondly, which of these two approaches here would you find more convincing
to show that a problem is intractable?
So please give me your two answers in these bubbles.